[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
ERIK DEMAINE: All right.
Welcome back to 006 and our
dynamic programming quadruple
of lectures.
We are over halfway through,
into lecture three of four.
Today, we're going to follow
up on this idea of problem
constraints and expansion that
was mentioned, especially,
towards the end of last lecture.
We saw an example of subproblem
expansion by a factor of 2
in the two-player
game with coins
where we wanted to have
two versions of the game,
one where I go first and
one where you go first.
So this was expanding the
number of such problems
by a factor of 2.
Today, we'll see a bunch
more examples of this idea,
including in one setting
we've seen already,
which is Bellman-Ford,
which you can
think of as a dynamic program.
Maybe it's a good
time to mention
that Bellman invented dynamic
programming in the '50s.
Same Bellman in the
Bellman-Ford algorithm.
This was actually an
independent discovery
by both of them--
and other people.
He invented dynamic programming,
and then, a few years later, he
applied it to solve the
single-source shortest paths
problem.
We saw them in the other order.
We saw single-source
shortest paths first,
because it was a little easier.
And now we're seeing the general
framework that this fits into.
And so we'll see how that works.
Why did Bellman call
dynamic programming
dynamic programming?
Mostly because it
sounded cool, and he
was trying to impress government
agencies giving him grants.
I mean, how can you argue with
something as cool-sounding
as dynamic programming?
But there is some logic to it.
Programming is a reference to
an old form of this word, which
means optimization.
And generally, we're
trying to optimize things.
And instead of
optimizing according
to some static kind of
approach or program,
we're doing it dynamically.
This is a reference to the
local brute force we're doing
to optimize at each stage.
You can't tell, at
the top, what you're
going to do in the middle.
And so it's kind of--
each subproblem is
behaving differently.
And so, in that sense, dynamic.
And it sounds cool.
All right.
Then we'll go to
all-pairs shortest paths.
We'll see a new algorithm for
that that's not asymptotically
any better, but it's
nice and simple,
and another way to-- a cool way
to see subproblem expansion.
And then we'll look at a couple
of sort of practical problems--
parenthesizing
arithmetic expressions
and a real-world problem,
piano and guitar fingering,
so assigning a fingering
how to play a piece.
And we're going to do that
with our SRTBOT framework.
Quick recollection
of what that is.
We define subproblems.
And we saw how to do
that for sequences.
We try either prefixes,
suffixes, or substrings.
We prefer prefixes and suffixes
because there's fewer of them.
If there's more
than one sequence,
we take the product
of those spaces.
And then the idea we're
going to stress today
is, we can always
add subproblems
to make the next step easier.
In particular, adding
constraints to subproblems,
in some sense, lets us remember
things about the subproblem
that's calling us--
or about the past,
is one way to think about it--
or in general, to
"remember state."
Just by adding more subproblems,
we can remember more stuff--
not just what things we're
working on, but some context.
And that's what we'll see
lots of examples of today.
It will hopefully make sense
by the end of the lecture.
Then, we need to relate these
subproblems with the recurrence
relation--
actually, we usually
just call it a relation.
And the key idea here is
to come up with a question
that, if you knew the
answer to that question,
you could reduce the
subproblem you're
trying to solve to smaller
subproblem solutions.
This question is sort of
the fundamental aspect of--
some fundamental
aspect of a solution.
Typically, when you're
dealing with suffixes,
you want to ask some question
about the first item, s of i.
When you're dealing
with prefixes,
you want to ask a
question about some--
near the last item,
s of i minus 1.
And for substrings, who knows?
Somewhere in the middle.
We'll see an example
of that today.
Once you have-- oh,
this is a reveal.
Something coming later.
Once you have identified
such a question,
the dynamic programming
approach is,
don't be smart about how
to answer that question--
just locally brute force.
Try all possible
answers to the question.
For each one, recurse,
and take the best solution
according to whatever metric
you're trying to do, typically
minimization or maximization.
Another way to think of
this local brute force,
which I like to
think in my head--
so maybe some people like
this, some people don't--
is to think about guessing
the answer to the question.
So maybe the answer
could be 0, 1, or 2.
And my algorithm will say,
guess which is the right answer.
And I'll assume that my
algorithm correctly guesses
the answer and analyze that.
So we can think of the program
as going straight through--
guessing the answer
and then recursing,
and then combining
the solutions however.
But then, at the
end, of course, we
can't assume that the
guess was correct.
In fact, we have to loop
over all of those guesses.
So it's the same thing.
Just, if you think
of it this way,
there's less looping
in your program.
But when you analyze
it, definitely, the loop
is really there.
You have to pay for all
of the possible answers.
OK.
Then we need to make sure
this relation is acyclic,
get a subproblem DAG.
And I like to specify an
explicit topological order
to make that clear.
We have base cases
for the relation.
We have to solve
the original problem
in terms of these
subproblems, and then we
analyze the running
time, usually,
as the number of subproblems
times the non-recursive work
in the relation.
So recursion is free
because we're multiplying
by the number of subproblems.
You can also sum
over the subproblems.
Sometimes that gives
you a tighter bound.
And then, of
course, we also have
to add on the running time we
spend in the original problem.
All right.
That was a quick recap.
Now, one problem we saw
in this framework two
lectures ago-- the
first lecture was
single-source shortest
paths in a DAG,
which, a lot of dynamic
programs actually
can be reduced to a
single-source shortest paths
in a DAG.
In fact, the reverse is true.
Single-source shortest paths
in a DAG can be thought of.
The DAG relaxation
algorithm we saw
is essentially a dynamic program
where the subproblems are
delta of s, v. The relation
of delta of s, v is the min.
So what are we
thinking about here?
We're guessing-- this is sort
of a new phrase I want to add.
Actually, I wrote it right here.
The last edge, u, v, on
a shortest s to v path.
That's a delta of
s, v. The problem
we're trying to solve is,
find shortest s to v path.
And it's some path, and we
don't know what it looks like,
but some feature of the
solution of this path
we're trying to find is,
well, what's the last edge?
It comes from some vertex here,
unless the path is of length 0
and s equals v. That's
a special case dealt
with in the base case.
Otherwise, there's
some vertex u before v.
We don't know what
it is, so we're
going to locally brute force, or
guess what the right answer is.
So look at all
incoming edges from u
to v, and for each of them,
take the recursive shortest path
from s to u, plus the
weight of the edge.
So this is the guessing or
local brute force perspective.
And the reason this works
is because G is acyclic,
and so it has a
topological order.
Otherwise, if the
graph has a cycle--
and that's the case we
want to go to next--
this recursive call from
delta of s, v to delta of s,
u will have loops in it.
And so you'll never
evaluate this recursion.
You'll never finish.
You'll never minimalize.
You'll be sad.
It will take infinite time.
So don't use this algorithm
unless you have a DAG.
For DAG, it's great.
It's linear time.
So that was a little review.
Now, here is a
single-source shortest paths
in general graphs, which
we know as Bellman-Ford,
but rephrased into
the SRTBOT framework.
So we defined this problem,
in the Bellman-Ford lecture,
delta sub k of s,
v. Remember, this
was the weight of a
shortest path from s
to v that is restricted
to use, at most, k edges.
This made the problem feasible.
We ended up taking the
product of the graph
into all of these different
subproblems, in fact.
But from the perspective
of dynamic programming,
we think of this as a
subproblem constraint.
What we really want is
the shortest s to v path,
but that's hard.
So we're going to break
it up into smaller pieces.
For each k between
0 and v, we're
going to say, well, let's think
about this problem restricted
to use, at most, k edges.
And for simple paths, if there
are no negative weight cycles,
we only have to go
up to v minus 1.
We proved that.
And we know we're--
then we're happy.
But that's sort of the last
thing we want to solve.
So if we look down at the
original problem we want,
it's delta sub v minus
1 of s, v for all v.
So if we could solve
these subproblems,
as we saw with
Bellman-Ford, we can
solve the original
problem-- unless there
are negative weight cycles.
And we use delta sub v of s,
v to check whether they're
negative weight cycles.
I don't want to repeat
that, but that's the all
in the original problem.
And then we can
take this relation
that we wrote for
DAG shortest paths
and just port it over here.
So remember, for
a general graph,
this has cycles,
so we can't use it,
because we're just referring
to arbitrary delta of s,
vs, so there's no reason
to expect no cycles there.
In fact, the call graph
is exactly the graph G,
so it has a cycle if
and only if G does.
But now, over here, I'm running
exactly the same formula
for this min, but I
added a sub k here
and a sub k minus 1
here, the observation
being, if I've
already guessed what
the last edge u, v
is for this path,
then if this whole thing
has length at most k,
then this piece has
length at most k minus 1.
So I only need to solve delta
sub k minus 1 of s, v here.
And so that's what I
wrote-- sorry, of s, u.
That's what I wrote here.
There's one other
thing, which is,
as I mentioned a
little while ago,
it could be that we
use fewer than k edges.
And so let's consider
the case where
we don't follow the last edge,
and we just add to this min
the shortest path using,
at most, k minus 1 edges.
That's one option for
having, at most, k edges.
If we wrote equality
here, then we
would remove that, like
the last problem section.
OK, good.
The key observation here is
that this recurrence does not
have cycles.
Just by adding this index,
if we solve these problems
in order of increasing k, all
of the references from delta sub
care in terms of
delta k minus 1.
And so this is now
magically acyclic.
This is why Bellman-Ford worked.
But now, I think in
a very pleasing way,
we're taking our graph acyclic.
And by spreading it out
over various copies of k
and referencing always
the smaller one,
we get an acyclic graph--
acyclic relations.
We have base cases, like normal.
And then we can analyze
the running time
in the usual way,
which is summing--
how much does this cost?
We're going to take the cost of
computing the relation, which
is the number of
incoming edges to v--
that's this theta-- and then
some overall subproblem.
So sum over k and
sum over v. Wrote it
as a sum instead of a
product because this thing
is theta E. The sum of incoming
edges over all vertices
is exactly the size of
E. And then we sum--
there's no k in this formula,
so we just multiply by v
and we get v E. So our good
friend Bellman-Ford recast
kind of the opposite way.
Before, we were
using relaxations.
Now, we're just writing
the min explicitly.
But essentially the
same computation, just
in a different order.
OK, cool.
Those are reviews
of old algorithms,
but in this new framework
to show how powerful it is.
Let's look at another
example, which is our friend--
right here-- all-pair
shortest paths.
A few lectures ago, we
saw Johnson's algorithm,
which solves this very well.
So one option we
could use is just
this same set of subproblems,
but for all u and v.
For u and v and v--
that's what we
really care about.
And then we could say k up
to v. Something like that.
So this would work, but it
would give the same running time
as running Bellman-Ford v times.
This is one solution
we know, but not
the best solution we know, for
how to solve shortest paths.
This would give v squared E,
which is at most v to the 4th.
For dense graphs, it
is theta v to the 4th.
So this is v times v
times v. But worst case
is v to the 4th
what I would like
to show you now
is a different way
to solve this problem--
almost identical, but gives
v cubed running time, which, for
dense graphs, is really good.
So we're going to reduce
this 4 down to a 3.
And this is an algorithm
called Floyd-Warshall.
It's definitely not
an obvious algorithm.
It's a very cool idea.
And it's a nice example
of a different way--
remember, this is
subproblem expansion.
We took the problems we
cared about multiplied
by this choice of k.
Here, we're going to
do the same thing,
but define it differently.
We're going to define those
subproblems differently.
First, I want to
number the vertices,
starting at 1 for convenience.
So let's see, y--
and then we're going to
define some subproblems, which
are delta--
I'll call it u, v, comma k.
Maybe, to avoid conflict,
I will write a d here.
This is just a definition
local to this algorithm.
So I want the weight of
shortest s to v path.
So far, just the same
as the problem we
actually want to solve.
This is delta of--
sorry, u, v. But I'm going to
add a constraint, which is,
using only vertices in
u, v and 1 to up to k.
This is the divine inspiration
to define subproblems this way.
It's a different constraint
than the one we saw here,
which was using,
at most, k edges.
So in some sense,
what's slow about
this algorithm is that
we have to loop over
all of the incoming vertices.
This is expensive.
Costs order the degree,
which ends up with an E term.
We're going to try to convert
that E term into a v term
by just knowing which
vertex to come from--
which sounds impossible.
But it turns out, if you write
the subproblems this way--
so I'm naming the vertices.
And say, well, let me just
find a path that uses u,
v and the vertex labeled 1.
There's only, like, two options.
I could go straight from u to v,
or I could go from u to 1 to v.
And then, how about with 1
and 2, and 1 and 2 and 3?
The same vertices.
By label instead of
by counting them.
Slight tweak, but it turns out
this speeds up the algorithm.
So let me first tell you how
many subproblems there are.
This is v cubed subproblems.
Two choices for u and v,
and I have v choices for--
sorry, I have v choices
for u, v choices for v,
and v choices for k, roughly.
v cubed of these.
But the key thing is--
that sounds like a lot.
But the relation
becomes cheaper now,
because I can just
write delta u--
sorry, d of u v k is the
min of two things, d of u,
v, k minus 1 and d of u,
k, k minus 1, plus d of k,
v, k minus 1.
It's a strange formula
because we're using indices
like k for vertices also, as
well as u and v for vertices,
but we're also using
k as a counter.
But we can do this because
our vertices are numbered.
OK.
So the idea is the following.
We have vertex u, have a
vertex v. And we've already
found the shortest path
that uses vertices 1
through k minus 1.
That's what this quantity is.
So it could be--
and now, we're trying
to add in this vertex k
and think about, what are
all the paths that could
go from u to v using 1 up to k?
Well, it could be the
shortest path from u
to v using 1 up to k
doesn't use vertex k.
That's the first option.
Just use vertices
1 up to k minus 1.
Maybe we don't need to use k.
Or it could be that the
path goes through k.
Well, it starts at
u, and it goes to k,
and then it goes from
k to v, all using--
for simple paths, if we assume
there are no negative weight
cycles and you have to run
Bellman-Ford to detect them--
but assuming no negative
weight cycles, the shortest
path from u to v through k must
start by using vertices less
than k and then use
vertices less than k again.
And that's what
I've written here.
It's from u to k using k minus
1 up to k minus 1 labels,
and from k to v using
labels up to k minus 1.
The cool thing here is,
the min only has two terms.
So this takes constant
time non-recursive work.
So this is, k is not
on the shortest path.
And this is, k is on
the shortest path.
Cool.
So this is constant
non-recursive work.
If we jump ahead to the running
time for this algorithm,
we get the number of
subproblems, which is v cubed,
times the amount of work per
subproblem, which is constant.
So that's just a
v cubed algorithm.
For dense graphs,
this is really good.
When E is v squared, then this
is the same thing as v times E,
so as good as Bellman-Ford.
It's not as good as
Johnson for sparse graphs.
Sparse graphs, remember--
or, in general, with Johnson,
we got v squared log n
plus v. And this is always
spending v cubed.
But it's cool because it's
a very simple algorithm.
Let's quickly write
the topological order.
All we need is to guarantee that
we solve problems in increasing
k order, because
every reference here
is to a smaller k for
the third argument.
And so, for example,
you can just
write a triply nested loop--
k equals 0, 1 up to v,
and u and v, and v and v.
So if you wanted to write
this algorithm bottom-up,
you just write this
triple four-loop
and then plug in this
recurrence relation here.
And think of d as a
table, as a set mapping,
instead of as a function call.
And boom, in four lines,
you've got your algorithm--
except you also
need a base case.
The base case here is u, v, 0.
So I have to define
what that means.
But when k equals 0, the
1 through k set is empty.
So all I'm allowed to use
are my vertices u and v.
There are three cases for this--
0 if u equals v. It's w of u, v
if there's an edge from u to v.
And it's infinity otherwise.
OK.
But easy base case,
constant time for each.
And then the original
problems we want to solve
are delta u, v, size of
v. Because I remember
the vertices 1 through size of
v. And if k equals size of v,
that means I get to
use all of my vertices.
So that is regular
shortest paths.
This is assuming no
negative weight cycles.
We already know how to
do negative weight cycle
detection, so I'm not going
to talk about that again.
But then, this will be my
shortest pathway because--
yeah.
I implicitly assumed here
that my path was simple
because I imagined that
I only use k once--
0 or 1 time.
And that's true if there are
no negative weight cycles.
Cool.
And we already did the
time part of SRTBOT.
So v cubed algorithm.
Very simple.
Basically, five lines
of code, and you've
got all-pairs shortest paths.
And if your graph is dense,
this is a great running time.
If your graph is not
dense, you should
use Johnson, like you will in--
or like you have implemented
in your problem set.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So how does
this this compare
to just running Dijkstra's
algorithm a bunch of times?
ERIK DEMAINE: What
about using Dijkstra?
Let's compute.
Running Dijkstra v times is
the running time of Johnson.
Running Dijkstra
a bunch of times
is great if your graph has
only non-negative edge weights.
Then you should
just run Dijkstra.
You get this running time.
And for sparse graphs,
this is superior.
If you have negative
edge weights,
you should run Johnson, which
is Bellman-Ford once and then
Dijkstra three times.
And we're comparing this to
v cubed, which we just got.
So this-- I mean,
how these compare
depends on how v and E relate.
On the one hand,
maybe v is theta E.
That's what I would call
a very sparse graph.
And it's quite common.
Then, the running time we
get here is v squared log v--
roughly v squared.
On the other hand, if we
have a very dense graph,
v is theta E squared--
which, for simple graphs, is
the most we could hope for--
then this running
time is v cubed.
If you know the v
is near E squared,
then this is giving you v
cubed anyway, from the vE term.
So why not just
use this algorithm?
And often, you know, a
priori, whether your graph
is very sparse or very dense
or somewhere in between.
If it's somewhere
in between, you
should still use
Johnson's algorithm,
because you're going to get
the benefit from sparsity
and only have to pay this
vE instead of the v cubed.
But if you know ahead of
time, constant fraction
of the edges are
there, then just use--
or you have a small enough
graph that you don't care,
just Floyd-Warshall because
it's simple and fast.
Good question.
Any other questions?
This is an example of
subproblem expansion--
a very non-intuitive
one, where we use
some prefix of the vertices.
But notice, it's
prefixes again--
a number of the
vertices from 1 up to v.
And I took a prefix
of those vertices.
So I just solved the problem
using prefix vertices 1
through k.
So it's actually
a familiar idea.
If all you had seen are all
dynamic programming examples
of prefixes, suffixes,
substrings, actually,
it's pretty natural way
to solve shortest paths--
maybe even more
natural than this.
Anyway, all right.
Enough shortest paths.
Let's solve two
more problems that
are more in our
standard wheelhouse that
will involve sequences
of inputs, not graphs.
First one is arithmetic
parenthesization.
First, let me
define this problem.
OK.
We are given a formula
with, say, plus and times.
Let me give you an
actual example--
7 plus 4 times 3 plus 5.
Now, when you read this, because
you've been well-trained,
you think, OK, I'm going
to multiply 4 and 3 first
because that has a
higher precedence,
and then I'll add
the results up.
But what I'm going to let you do
is parenthesize this expression
however you want.
For example, you can add
parentheses here and here.
You must make a balanced
parenthesis expression,
a valid way to pair up--
or not just pair
up, but a valid way
to evaluate this expression.
Any order you want.
I could be inconsistent.
I could, for example, do this
sum, and then do this product,
and then do this sum.
But some kind of
expression tree over this.
And each one evaluates
to something.
This is 11 and this is
8, and so this is 88.
And my goal is to
maximize that computation.
And I claim that this
is the way to maximize
that particular example.
Let me write it in general,
and get my notation
to match my notes.
Given a formula a 0,
star 1, a 1, star 2, a 2,
and so on up to
star n minus 1, a n
minus 1, where each a
i is an integer, as we
like in this class, and each
star i is either plus or times.
OK so I'm using star
as a generic operator.
I chose star because it is
the superposition of star
on top of a times symbol.
So it's clear.
So you're given some formula,
any mixture of plus and times
that you like,
involving n integers.
And your goal is to
place parentheses
to maximize the result. So you
can try all of the combinations
here.
If I, for example, take the
product of 4 times 3, I get 12.
If I do that first, I get 12.
Then if I add 5 and 7, I get
24, which is less than 88.
And I check them
all, and this one
is the maximum for that example.
Interesting problem.
It's a bit of a toy
problem, but it's
motivated by lots of
actual problems, which
I won't go into here.
To apply this framework, we need
to identify some subproblems.
This is a sequence problem.
We're given a
sequence of symbols.
And so the natural thing is
to try prefixes, suffixes,
and substrings.
I'm going to jump ahead and
think about the relation first.
I want to identify some
question about a subproblem
or its solution
that would let me
reduce to smaller subproblems.
This is a little trickier.
This is very different.
We're not always doing something
on the left or on the right,
or we can't assume there's
something happening
on the left, because maybe we
take a product in the middle
first.
If I take a product
in the middle first,
then I have some result here,
but I still have three things.
I have the thing to the left,
I have the thing in the middle,
and I have the
thing on the right.
It turns out to be very
messy to think about what
the first operation is.
Because we can think
of this as a tree,
where we take a product here--
we take a sum of 7 and
4 and 3 and 5 over here
and then take the
product at the root.
But I don't know what
the tree is, right?
I only know these numbers
and these operators,
but I don't know how
to organize this tree.
The idea is, if you
think of this tree,
what is the one thing
that's easiest to identify?
It's the root.
The root corresponds
to the last operation
I do in this computation.
The last thing I did
was take a product.
And that's a lot easier, because
if I guess who is at the root--
which operator is at the root--
that naturally decomposes
into the left subtree
and the right subtree.
And those will
always be substrings.
We kind of know this.
This node corresponds
to everything
left of this operator, and
this substring or this subtree
corresponds to everything to
the right of the operator.
So this is our idea, is we're
going to guess which operation,
star i, is evaluated last--
or, in other words, at the root.
So this is the question.
It has n possible answers--
I guess, actually, n
minus 1 from operator 1,
operator n minus 1.
And so we'll just brute
force all of those choices.
I wanted to start here because--
to realize that if,
I choose some star
i in the middle, which
might be the right thing,
like in this example.
Star i is the middle one--
middle operator.
I naturally decompose
into everything
to the left of that
operator and everything
to the right of that operator.
This is a prefix.
This is a suffix.
So you might think, oh, my
subproblems are all prefixes
and all suffixes.
But that would be
wrong, because if you
have a bunch of operators--
and say you choose
this one to be last.
So I have a prefix
here and a suffix here.
And then there will be some--
within this suffix, I'll
choose some operator
to be the root of that
one, and I have a prefix
and a suffix of this suffix.
But in particular, I
will have to evaluate
this subproblem, which
is a prefix of a suffix--
in other words, a substring.
So never use a mixture
of prefixes and suffixes.
If you need both, you
probably need all substrings.
So our subproblems are
going to be substrings.
OK.
I'm not going to write
the subproblems quite yet,
because there's
another idea we need.
So what do I need to
do with the substring?
I'm going to guess
the middle operator
and then evaluate
the left substring,
evaluate the right substring.
What am I trying to do
with those substring?
I guess I'm trying to
solve this problem, which
is, place parentheses in
order to maximize the result,
and then return
what the result is.
And I can use paren
pointers to reconstruct what
the parentheses actually are.
Once I guess what
the last operator
is, it enough to maximize
the part to the right
and maximize the
part to the left?
Will that always maximize
my sum or product
according to what
this operator is?
And if you think
about it for a while.
Yeah.
If I want to maximize the sum,
I should maximize the two parts.
And if I want to
maximize a product,
I should maximize the two parts.
That seems right.
Except, I didn't say that
my integers are positive.
That's true if your
integers are positive.
But to make this problem
more interesting,
we're going to allow the
integers to be negative.
For example, 7 plus minus
4 times 3 plus minus 5.
So I just added a
couple of minuses
to a couple of the numbers here.
Then it's no longer best
to pair them this way.
If I pair them this
way, like this,
or if I add parentheses
this way, I get 3 here,
and I get minus 2 here.
So I get-- the product
of that is negative 6,
which i probably
not the maximum.
In fact, I can do
better, I believe,
by doing the left operator last.
So this, I claim, the
best parenthisization,
if I remembered it correctly.
This is, minus 2 times
minus 4 is 8, plus 7 is 15.
So I got a positive
number-- definitely
better than the
negative number I got.
I claim this is the best.
And the key property
here is, when
we take a product of
two negative numbers,
we get a positive number.
Sometimes, you actually
want to make things small,
because small might
mean very negative.
You take two very big
negative numbers--
very small negative
numbers, in other words.
You take their product, you get
a very big product, positively,
because the signs cancel.
OK.
So this seems tricky.
We want to work on
substrings, but we
don't know whether we're
trying to maximize,
or you might think,
well, maybe I'm
trying to maximize
the absolute value.
But that's not good.
Maybe overall, on this
entire expression,
I get negative 1 million.
And that's not what I wanted.
I wanted to maximize the sum.
So I still need to
solve the max evaluation
that I can get, the
max parenthesization,
but I also need to solve
the min parenthesization.
If I can solve max and min,
I'll know the entire range
that I could get.
And I really only--
I'll care about min especially
when it lets me go negative.
But let's just solve, in all
cases, the min and the max,
and then just brute
force the rest.
That's what I'm
going to write down.
So that was some motivation
and why we are going
to define subproblems this way.
I'm going to define x of i,
comma j, comma opt to be--
opt, here, is going to
be either min or max.
And this is my
subproblem expansion.
I really just care about
max at the very end,
but I'm going to care
about min along the way.
And i, j is going to
specify my substring.
So this is going to
be the opt value--
opt stands for "optimum"
here, or "optimization."
The opt value I can get for
the substring a i star plus 1,
a i plus 1, and so on to
star j minus 1, a j minus 1.
OK.
Being careful to get my
indices correct here.
And I want 0 less than or
equal to i, less than j,
less than equal to n.
I claim and opt like this.
OK.
I'm going to get the min value
and the max value separately.
Those are two
different subproblems.
This is my expansion.
This is the
constraint I'm adding.
And I'm only focusing on this
substring from i inclusive
to j exclusive.
OK.
So I claim those are
good subproblems.
Let's write down a
recurrence relation.
OK.
Relate.
I want to write x of
i, j, opt on the left.
And I want to optimize-- so
this will be min or max--
on a set of choices.
What is my set of choices?
Well, like I said,
I want to guess
what is the last
operation evaluated.
I wrote star i here, but
star i is already defined,
so I'm going to use star k.
So I'm going to guess which
of my operations between i
plus 1 and j minus 1 is the
last one, and I evaluate.
And that decomposes
everything left of k.
So that would be x of i,
comma k, comma something.
And then we will do
operator star k on the part
after k, which is from
k to j, something.
And I'm choosing between--
I think it's i less
than k less than j.
k is some operator in between,
because I started i plus 1
and I ended j minus 1.
So those are the
possible choices for k.
I tried them all.
That's my local brute force.
And then I take what I
can get on the left, what
I can get on the right,
and multiply or add them
according to whether the
operator is plus or times.
Now, should I maximize
or minimize this one?
Should I maximize or
minimize this one?
I don't know.
So I'm just going to do
more local brute force.
Well, let's just say
opt prime for the left--
or maybe I'll call
it opt L for the left
and opt R for the right part.
And I'll just add
this to my four-loop.
Let's just try opt L and opt R.
Just take all possible choices
among min and max.
Now, you could think hard--
and for addition, for example,
if you're maximizing,
you really only
need to maximize the two parts.
And if you're minimizing,
you can prove you all
need to minimize the two parts.
But for multiplication,
it's messy.
It could be, really,
any of the options.
Because sometimes,
when you minimize,
you get a negative term.
Sometimes, you don't.
And so it depends what
you're trying to do.
You have to consider
all the signs.
But we don't need to think hard.
We can just try all options.
There's only four
choices for opt L
and opt R among min and max.
You could do min-min,
min-max, max-min, and max-max.
So try-- it's just a
multiplication by 4
in this four-loop.
The big cost is
actually this one,
because there are j
minus i choices for k.
There's a constant number of
choices for opt L and opt R.
And you need to prove
that this is correct.
I won't do it here.
But the idea is, if you're
trying to minimize or maximize
your sum or product,
it's enough to know what
ranges these could come in.
And the optimal
choice will always
be an extreme in that range.
We consider all of them here.
And so we get this recurrence.
Now, it needs a base
case, and we need
to check that it's acyclic.
But topological order is
just increasing j minus i.
This is the usual order
for substring problems,
because this is increasing
length of the substring.
So start with very
tiny substrings.
Here, we'll start with
length 1 substrings.
We just have an a, i there.
So that's going to
be our base case.
And you grow up to
the entire string.
And it doesn't
matter how we order
relative to opt as long as we
are increasing in j minus i,
because i to k and
k to j will always
be strictly smaller than i to
j, and so this will be acyclic.
The base case is x
of i, i plus 1, opt.
This is always a i.
Doesn't matter what
opt is, because there's
nothing-- there's no choice.
You just have a single
number in that substring,
because we're
exclusive on i plus 1.
And then the original
problem we want to solve
is x of 0, n, max.
You could also solve min and
see how small you can get it.
So if you wanted to
maximize the absolute value,
you could solve the max
problem and the min problem
and take the largest
of those two options.
And how much time
does this take?
Well, how many
subproblems are there?
For substring problems, we
have n squared subproblems.
Now, we multiply the
number of subproblems by 2,
but that's still n squared.
So we have n
squared subproblems.
And how much work per
subproblem are we doing?
Well, as I mentioned, we're
doing j minus i choices for k
and a constant number of
choices for opt L and opt R.
So this is theta j minus i,
which, if I'll be sloppy,
that's at most big O of n.
And it turns out to be
the right answer anyway.
So there's a linear amount
of non-recursive work.
In fact, it's like
a triangular number,
but that's still theta n cubed.
Same running time as
v cubed we just got.
But polynomial time.
And this is pretty impressive,
because we're really
brute forcing all possible
parenthesizations.
There about 4 to the
n, exponentially many,
parenthesizations
of an expression.
But we're finding the biggest--
the one that evaluates the
largest value and the one that
evaluates to the
smallest value in just n
cubed time-- polynomial.
And a key here was
subproblem expansion,
where we, in addition to
solving the max problem,
we also solved the min
problem, because sometimes, you
want to take two very
small negative numbers
and product them together to
get a larger positive number.
Cool.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Would
anything go wrong
if I added minus or divide?
ERIK DEMAINE: So what if I had
operators minus and divide?
It's a good question.
I'm certain that minus
should work fine.
If we do min and max,
this should still
evaluate the largest
thing for division.
I need to think about the cases.
I would guess it
works, but what we
need to prove is that the
way to maximize or minimize
a division, say, given two
numbers in the left and right,
is that it either corresponds
to maximizing or minimizing
the thing on the left and
then maximizing or minimizing
the thing on the right.
So as long as you have
this kind of-- it's
not exactly monotonicity.
It's just that, in order
to compute max or min,
it suffices to know the max
and min of the two parts.
It's like interval arithmetic.
You know, interval arithmetic?
I want to know, what
are the extremes I
can get on the
output of a division
if I'm given that a number
is in some interval here
and some interval here?
If the answer is always, use
one of the extreme endpoints
here and use one of the
extreme endpoints here,
then this algorithm will work.
Otherwise, all bets are off.
Cool.
So if you negate--
if you put a minus here,
that will work fine,
because it's
negating this range.
And then it's just like sum.
But--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: Oh, a divider--
if you're careful about 0, yeah.
Actually, it doesn't
work, because we
care about how close this
can get to 0 for division.
It might be enough
to consider those.
It's like, instead of minimizing
and-- instead of computing this
entire interval, if
this interval spans 0,
maybe I need to know--
if 0 is here, I need
to know how close to 0
I can get on the left
side and how close to 0
I can get on the right side.
Still just four
quantities I need to know.
I would guess, for
division, that's enough.
Yeah.
Nice.
Solved a little problem.
Then, we would be multiplying
the subproblem space,
instead of by 2, by 4.
Hey, maybe we should
put this on the final.
No, just kidding.
Now it's in lecture,
so we can't use it.
But it's a cool set
of problems, right?
You can do a lot with
dynamic programming.
You don't need to be that
clever, just brute force
anything that seems hard.
And when it works,
it works great.
And this class is all about
understanding when it works
and when it doesn't work.
Of course, we will only give
you problems where it works.
But it's important to
understand when it doesn't work.
For example, DAG shortest
paths-- that algorithm
on a non-DAG, very bad.
Infinite time.
OK.
Our last example
is piano fingering.
Here, we're given a
sequence of notes t 0, t 1--
t for note-- up to t n minus 1.
These are single notes.
And all of the single notes--
all of the single notes, right?
And we have fingers
on our hands.
This is not like
two-finger algorithm.
This is the
five-finger algorithm.
So in general, I'm
going to assume
an arbitrary
anthropomorphic object.
So this is 5 for humans--
most humans.
Some humans-- I think the
maximum on each hand is 7.
Could be smaller.
Maybe you've had an accident.
I'll solve it for arbitrary F.
And what we would like to do
is assign fingers to notes
to tell our pianist which
finger to use for each note.
Normally, when you're
given sheet music,
it just gives you a sequence
of notes you want to play.
It doesn't tell you which
finger you want to play it with,
unless you have some
nice training booklets
and they have a little
number on top of each.
And I number them
1, 2, 3, 4 or 5,
and symmetrically,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Here's a giant piano
for my giant hands.
If Jason were here, he
could sing these notes.
So maybe I play this
with my first finger,
this with my second finger.
Let's just say
I'm doing a scale.
So I can walk.
And now, I think,
the typical way
to do a scale is to reach
over with your first finger--
second finger, I guess, and
then do something like this.
No?
OK.
Clearly, I don't know scales
or how to play a piano.
But there's limits here.
I can-- if I'm
going from this note
and I want to go to
another note over here,
OK, maybe I have a decent
span from first finger
to fifth finger, but my
span for my first finger
to my second finger
is not as big.
I can't reach as far.
So if I want to play this
note and then this note,
I would like to start here
with a very extreme figure
on the left and then go to
at a very extreme figure
on the right.
I'm going to formalize this
problem pretty abstractly,
because I don't want to
get into music performance.
I'm going to say that
there is a metric d for,
if I'm at note t
with finger f, and I
want to go to note
t prime with finger
f prime, then this function,
d of t, f, t prime, f prime,
gives me the difficulty
of doing that--
the difficulty of playing
note t with finger f
and then playing note t
prime with finger f prime.
This w is "with."
So this is a
transition difficulty.
I'm not going to worry about the
difficulty of the whole piece
other than saying, well,
I've got to play this note,
then I've got to play this note.
And for now, just single notes.
You play a single note
with your right hand,
then you play
another single note
with your right hand,
then another single note
with your right hand.
Let's assume no pauses
for now-- no rests.
Great.
So we have this difficulty
from going from the ith note
to the i plus first note.
And then our goal is to minimize
the sum of difficulties.
Minimum sum of d ti
fi ti plus 1, plus 1.
And these-- f i's and f i plus
1 is what we want to compute.
We don't know which
fingers to use.
We're only given
which notes to play.
This is actually
a natural problem.
There are lots of papers
about this problem.
I've read a bunch of them--
obviously not super well,
but how to play scales.
But there are notes like--
there are constraints
in this-- usually,
people write this metric as a
sum of different penalty terms,
if I want to
minimize difficulty.
Difficulty is high if I
play a note far on the left.
So if I go from a low
note to a high note,
that's easier to do if I
use a lower-numbered finger
and go to a
higher-numbered finger.
You don't want to
go, like I was doing,
from a high-numbered finger
to a low-numbered finger
to play a note on the right.
That's annoying.
I would like to do an
assignment, if I can,
that avoids that.
So I'll just have some penalty
of, like, 100 if that happens,
and 0 if it doesn't happen, sum
up a bunch of terms like that.
Other examples are, avoid the
fourth and fifth fingers--
weak fingers--
or, if I'm playing a portion
of the song that is legato,
then I don't want to
use the same finger
to play two notes
right after the other.
I've got to use two
different fingers for that.
So you have a penalty if f i
equals f i plus 1 and these two
notes are not the same.
Then-- and we're
in legato mode--
then we add a penalty term.
And things like that.
I would prefer-- if I'm going
from a very low note to a very
high note, I would like to
use more extreme fingers.
Things like that.
But we're just going to assume
this d function is given to us.
It's some polynomial size.
If you imagine the
notes on your keyboard
are end notes or m notes, then
some polynomial and m size
to this function.
How do we solve this problem?
I'm running low on time, so
let me give you the idea.
And this is going to use
subproblem expansion.
So the subproblems are going
to be x of i, comma f--
this is the minimum total
difficulty to play suffix--
because I like suffixes--
t i up to t n minus 1, starting
with finger f on note t i.
The obvious subproblems would
be without this constraint.
This here is a
problem constraint.
And you could try to define
the subproblems just as,
what's the best way
to play a suffix?
But I claim it's
important to know
which finger we start with.
So we're going to multiply
the number of subproblems
by capital F, which is just 5.
So a very small
subproblem expansion.
And then we're
going to constrain
these subproblems to
say, well, what if I
started with my first finger?
What if I started
with my second finger?
What if-- up to
the fifth finger.
Try them all.
Then, it turns out, I can
write a relation, which
is X of i f equals the min.
What should I min over?
I'll just guess this--
I'm already told what my
first finger is to use--
which finger I
should use for t i.
So what's the next
thing that matters?
Well, I guess what finger
to use for the t i plus 1,
the very next note.
What is the next finger I use?
I will call that f
prime and minimize over
f prime, between
one and capital,
F of the remaining
suffix, starting
with f prime, plus my difficulty
function from t i, comma f,
to t i plus 1, comma f prime.
End of bracket.
OK.
So there's kind of
a lot going on here.
This is a lowercase f prime.
But actually, if
you think about what
I would like to write
the recurrence on,
well, I start with
the suffix i, I
would like to recurse
on the smaller suffix,
so that's X of i plus 1.
So here, if I know that
I'm prioritizing my finger
number for i, will
then I'm in order
to even call this
function, I need
to know what finger
I'm using 4 plus 1.
Once you decide on
these subproblems,
it's really obvious you need to
guess, what is the next finger,
and then recurse
on that finger--
recurse on the remaining
suffix of that finger.
Now, why did we need to know
what these fingers were?
Why not just guess what
the first finger is?
Well, it has to do with
this difficulty function.
For this difficulty
function, I know
that I want to measure
the difficulty from t i
to t i plus 1.
And to do that, because this
function is parameterized
by four things, I need to
know both the finger for t i
and, at the same time,
the finger for t i plus 1.
If I remove this f, I could
add a min over one finger,
but I can't really add
a min over two fingers.
So what this does, by
parameterizing by f here
and writing down the optimal
for each starting finger f,
I can-- in some sense,
I'm remembering,
in this call, what
finger I started with.
Because I told it, you have
to start with finger f prime.
And so locally to X i, f,
I know what finger f prime
is being used for t i plus 1.
And also, because of the
definition of X i, f,
I know what finger
I'm using for t i.
And so I get to know
both of these fingers.
One comes out of this
min and the other
is given to me as
this parameter.
And then, of course, if I
can solve these problems,
I can solve the original problem
by just one more min of 1
up to capital F of x 0 little f.
I don't know which
finger to start with,
but that's just f choices.
And so then, this recurrence
gives me the overall solution.
And I'll just jump to the time.
We need a base case
and topological order.
But it is n f squared time.
There are n times
f subproblems here.
And for each one, I'm doing an
optimization over f choices,
so I get n times f squared.
It's a polynomial.
And if f is a constant, this
is actually linear time.
Very fast DP.
Now, what I described
here is for one hand,
one note at a time.
But you can generalize this to
two hands, each with one note.
Well, that's just ten fingers.
So you could solve this
separately for the right hand
and left hand if you know
which notes are being played
with left hand and right hand.
But some pieces,
that's not obvious.
So to make it more interesting,
what if you have multiple notes
at the same time?
And let's say--
I think it's reasonable to say
you can only play up to f notes
at a time, 1 for each finger.
And so you have an upper
bound on the number
of notes at a time that
we're playing, which is good.
Oh, I have a drawing
of this DP, by the way,
as a subproblem DAG.
This is the original
problem, which
is, we don't know which
finger to start with.
But then we just have a
complete bipartite graph here,
where we write on each
of these edges, what
is the difficulty
of this transition?
The y-axis here is
which finger I'm using--
1, 2, 3, 4, 5--
and the x-axis is
which suffix I'm considering.
Which note do I start on?
And so you could solve this
with shortest paths in a DAG,
or you could just
solve it directly
as DP, either
top-down or bottom-up.
OK.
Jumping ahead, if you do
multiple notes at a time,
instead of this finger choice,
which just had f choices,
we have--
what do I write here?
t to the f possible
states, where
t is the maximum number of
notes that I could play at once.
And usually, this is at
most f, 1 for finger.
But we could generalize.
And this is number of fingers.
So I could deal with all 10
fingers of a typical human set
of arms--
hands-- and say
there's at most 10.
And so this is 10 to the 10.
It's a big constant,
but it's constant--
like 1 billion right?
10 billion?
But then it's that times n.
And maybe that
squared times n will
let me exhaustively enumerate
all of the possible things
I could do be doing
with all of my hands.
You can apply this not
only to piano fingering,
but also to guitar
fingering-- also to Rock Band.
Rock Band is an easy
case where you just
have five buttons, and usually
only four fingers that you use.
And this doesn't
really make any sound,
so it's not that exciting.
So the case where f equals 4 you
can apply to optimally figure
out which finger-- once you have
a difficulty function of what
transitions are easy
and hard for Rock Band,
then you can optimally
figure out your fingering
for Rock Band songs.
With a real guitar, this
is a little bit harder
because there are
actually multiple ways
to play the same note.
For example, I can play the
note of this string like this.
These should both
sound the same--
if my guitar were perfectly
tuned, which it's not.
And that's properties
of strings and the way
these things are played.
So in addition to
what finger I use,
I should also decide which
string to play that note on.
If all I'm given is sheet
music, different notes to play,
another thing I
could guess is which
string to play that note on.
So for example, maybe I want
to play my favorite song here.
[PLAYING MUSIC]
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
ERIK DEMAINE: Super Mario
Brothers, my favorite song.
I could keep going, but I
actually can't keep going.
It won't be as impressive.
I don't actually know
how to play guitar.
But there are a lot of
choices there, right?
I started with playing this
note down on this string.
That's good.
I could have also played
it on this string.
But that's more
work for my finger,
so I have a penalty
function that
says, well, if I play an open
string, that's a lot easier.
And then I had a
transition from here--
this note [PLAYING A NOTE]
to this note [PLAYING A NOTE]
to this note.
[PLAYING A NOTE] And if you
focus on my fingering here,
I chose to use my index
finger for the first one,
because that index finger is
always the easiest to use,
but it also gives
me lots of room
to move my pinky over to here.
And then I like to use my
middle finger to come up here.
You could also use
your index finger.
It's just a little
bit more of a reach.
So you have to define
some difficulty function.
It might depend on how
big your fingers are.
But you can do that,
and then optimize,
using these algorithms,
what is the best guitar
fingering for a given piece--
one note a time or
several notes at a time.
You could even add
in parameters like,
oh, maybe I want to play a bar.
That's not a perfect bar.
But this would be great
for my playing this note
down here and this note here--
bad example.
So you could do other
things with a guitar
to make it more interesting and
generalize this dynamic program
suitably.
But I think this
gives you a flavor
how, with subproblem
expansion, I
can capture almost any aspect
of a problem that I want.
As long as the number of states
that I need to keep track of
is small, I can just multiply
the number of subproblems
by that state, and I can keep
track of any kind of transition
from one state to another, which
I could also do with taking
the product of a graph.
But dynamic programming gives
you a kind of methodical way
to think about this, by
figuring out some property--
in this case, the state of
how my fingers are applied
to the instrument-- and then
just sort of brute forcing
the rest--
a very powerful framework.